hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 70 freakin seventy of
game programming so last time we took a
look at actually animating this awesome
freaking projectile is what it looks
like so that spring right now today
we're gonna take a look at actually
freaking not shooting grass but shooting
an actual projectile isn't that gonna be
so much better it is trust me okay so
that's literally all we're gonna do
today right our objective is to change
this grass thing into a texture so how
are we gonna do that well pretty pretty
awesomely that's how pretty damn awesome
that's that's freaking what it's gonna
be
so we've got this class called sprite a
Java it is in if I just undo this it is
in let's just undo the play shooting
thing
and there goes everything actually I was
fine here so it's in if I remember
correctly I think it's would be in
graphics right yep so in graphics we've
got a thing called spreadsheet Java wait
let's open that so over here we've got a
bunch of code for tiles in spawn level
right and if you guys recall we do have
a bit of a hierarchy going on we've got
um we've got in our resources folder we
got levels which has our level files and
we've got textures and intentions we've
got sheets and shades we've got spawn
level this is just as bad shape but
we've got spawn level right and that's
responsible for all the spawn stuff so
over here in sheets right let's create a
new finish I haven't sheets we should
really change some of these names tracks
they don't make any sense but Texas
shades okay in shades people just have
one cold projectiles right and I'm here
will make a new one so will making you
and will make it let's just say
projectiles depends whose projectiles
but let's just make it what it is now
which is just this one's 48 48 let's
make the other one the same thing right
so each tile is 16 and let's save it
into projectiles as oh maybe just well
since we're doing wizard once before in
wizard
okay so there's that the wizard
projectiles and let's do a few things
first of all let's just figure out how
big these guys should be so
that means there should be I believe
this stuff here and here and here
not to forget here and 16 by 16 so here
all right correct okay
let's pop these guys down and then we're
probably just pretty much copy and paste
this yeah okay
I guess now I've got a bunch of sprites
for control now one thing that we've
talked about and well you would have
seen in our normals brush shape
transparency right so we made
transparent color pink or in wheelin to
be exactly specific we made it this car
FF 0 0 FF so just remember that okay
because we obviously want to you know
maintain consistency in our program and
make stuff Inc anyway so let's just for
now let's just you know let's just be
cool right now it's not jump into
massive um you know projectile like an
hours spent on projectiles like during
them properly so what I'm gonna do here
is I'm just gonna make a ball right and
it will look like a ball when it's done
don't worry kind of incentive stuff
correctly okay
oops so probably just take out it look
good enough or should we make it even
higher as we could make it even higher
asking away and what I mean by that is
you know something like that like this
yeah I'll still like this that will look
nice why not
there we go so this will be our sprite
so this is what a projectile will look
like just for now okay what will
probably change us later I'll show you
guys how both animate it and rotate it
in game depending work where we shoot it
but for now we'll just leave it at that
so let's make a new sprite sheet and
we'll call it projectile wizard okay and
that will be in sheets projectiles right
the hierarchy we just made and it is a
wizard docked and J and the size of 48
all right same as held on because our
width is you see right here is 48 okay
so wait so we've got a new static sprite
sheet now now now we can use it as if it
was any other sprite so what we'll do
over here is if we go into projectile
over here you'll see that we've got a
wizard projectile right that's what
we're doing right now we're using now
right now we've set this practice right
grass all we have to do now is go into
our surprise and all we need to do here
is let's put a player sprites over here
projectile sprites here and over here
we'll just make a public ecstatic and
it's crops you guys gonna say probably
public static sprite projectile wizard
equals new sprite okay what's all that
stuff so 32 is eyes is that no sorry
that's sixteen sixteen is a size x and y
is just 0 0 and the sprite sheet that we
used is sprite sheet del projectile was
it I get and that's it that is as simple
as it is yeah okay I'm just checking to
see if everything's right looks pretty
good to me okay
so that's it that's just how simple it
is so over here in wizard shell in
Wizard projectile instead of setting
sprites apart across we can set sprite
DOS bright a sprite projectile was it
and that's it and if we run our game we
should see is us shooting a bunch Oh
pink things that do resemble a sprites
that's good news
now one thing that's not good news is
well the fact that they've got pink on
them and there's nothing wrong with pink
okay guys
but it's bad in a sense so let's do the
same thing that we did here right
literally the same so in so this is an
arrow no tile okay you guys didn't catch
this method did you this is what the
method looks like alright so copy this
down because I saw a bunch of you guys
were saying that I didn't write this in
front of you I'm not sure why I wouldn't
have but um you know I'm trusting you
guys more than myself so if you guys
didn't actually catch this method it's
this is what it looks like okay so it's
just um Runanga Tallis I think it's the
same as um we're Natalia you can
actually copy and paste on the tile in
fact list okay let's do something
different
Brenda Brenda projector I'm gonna lay my
render projector we shouldn't be using
this anywhere else to save this worked
we shouldn't be okay yep we're only
using it as you can see in with a
projectile that's good so I'm basically
just making a new method here called
range render projectile it's the same as
render tile so let's copy and paste that
basically and it's over sprite sprite
sorry instead of here being tile tile
we'll make it projectile paint right and
P dot sprite dot size okay
get out spread out size and same thing
everywhere except um let's import this
vessel okay so first of all okay that's
it yep okay cool let's go into
projectile and let's just um make a
method here called public sprite you get
sprite and it will just return a sprite
okay and we can probably also make
public int get sprite size and it will
return sprite sighs okay so just make it
really simple for us so over here all we
need since we use sprite sighs a lot
gets bright sighs okay so let's copy and
paste that everywhere we had size before
and and yeah we'll just just get sprite
here and by guess sprite I mean pee
darkest right it's close
so we're referring to a projectile okay
so wait so this looks pretty good um one
thing that we'll do though is we'll set
again we'll make the color equal to this
and we'll step colleague till here so
all I've done here is I've just made and
I pair up a lot of it and I'll just say
that if color happens to all if color
doesn't equal that color which we would
with the Alpha Channel so F F F F 0 0 FF
right so this is the pink color and this
is just the Alpha Channel then drove out
okay so let's try oops let's go back to
that was a projectile and change this to
render projectile and instead of sprite
as the parameter we'll just have it this
okay so let's run that and check that
out we are shooting black balls that
look really bad
let's go back into our texture quickly
and maybe just add a bit of a twinkle to
it okay so
maybe like a little gray somehow that
just to make it like a bit you know that
looks pretty bad isn't it right now if
there are any artists out there who
desperately want to help me stop
embarrassing myself please let me know
okay that would be greatly appreciated
thank you okay so that is that wraps up
this tutorial as you can see we've got a
nice little sprite now next time we want
to talk about well first of all fixing
these angles you can see that I'm aiming
here if I want to aim a bit lower it
doesn't change the logo there so in
other words it's not like preset
precision direction so we'll fix that
next time we'll also probably put a
limit on how fast we can shoot them you
can see we're shooting them really fast
and also while destroying them so I have
our FPS is going down but yeah anyway
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please hit the like button and I'll
see you guys tomorrow with a new episode
later guys
you